[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci pour la
pour la pression
parce que mettre HS en avant on va
rappeler quelqu'un c'est une pression
supplémentaire
mais j'espère que je vais arriver à m'en
sortir
je me présente pour ceux qui me
connaissent pas
je suis à Salto
je suis membre du groupe Magic System un
groupe d'artistes
ivoirien
et je viens d'un petit village qu'on
appelle en no Mambo
qui est mon repère qui est mon village
de
référence parce que même dans mes
réflexions les plus profondes mes
pensées vont toujours vers ce petit
village c'est ma source
et où ce soir je suis là pour partager
petite expérience avec vous on m'a dit
que j'ai 15 minutes j'espère pouvoir les
faire
on m'a dit qu'on va parler des rêves et
d'évolution pour faire révolution
moi j'ai voulu aller au-delà du rêve
je voulais aller au-delà du rêve parce
que pour moi
rêver tout le monde a un rêve et à nos
Mambo j'ai rêvé avec des gens
et
ce qui
est pertinent dans le rêve
c'est qu'on essaie de définir on se
projette
devant on se projette sur le ciel même
qu'on n'ose pas pouvoir faire mais on se
dit il faut qu'on crée toutes les
conditions pour pouvoir réaliser ses
rêves c'est pourquoi dans la vie il y a
deux catégories du rêveur
il y a ceux qui rêvent
et qu'il est réalise et à ceux qui ne
sortent pas de leur sommeil
qui reste dans le rêve
le rêve il faut travailler à le réaliser
et puis parvenir il faut une révolution
en soi-même
moi j'ai fait ma révolution dès le
départ
l'actualité aujourd'hui
c'est
ma diplomation à acheter
le monde entier allant parler j'ai vu
sur les médias à tel point que je me
suis posé la question est-ce que c'était
le plus haut diplôme de la vie quoi
parce que c'est un master je ne dirais
pas ce n'est qu'un master parce que moi
je sais ce que c'est
mais si
ma diplomération doit faire le tour du
monde j'imagine
de Amadou Bakayoko
qu'est-ce que ils vont dire vous avez vu
tout à l'heure
ça c'est des vrais diplômés là eux ils
ont eu ça il y a longtemps
nous on est allé dans la vie on est
revenu mais dans la vie à deux flèches
il y a ceux qui sont allés qui ont eu
des diplômes qui sont rentrés dans la
vie active
et à ceux qui sont allés dans la vie
active tu vas estimer qu'il y a quelque
chose qui manquait aux puzzle qui sont
revenus les chercher moi je suis de
cette catégorie
[Applaudissements]
un jour j'arrive sur le campus à HEC
ça c'est une petite anecdote que je vais
vous raconter
et je tombe sur un étudiant qui a à peu
près l'âge de ma fille tu me dis
mais vous c'est Magic System
qu'est-ce que vous faites à je sais
qu'est-ce que vous faites sur le campus
vous avez
un enfant ici
j'ai dit non je suis étudiant comme toi
il dit non c'est pas possible
vous avez la notoriété
la gloire tout le monde vous connaît
vous avez un statut dans la vie j'étais
récemment sur votre Wikipédia j'ai vu
que vous vous êtes même ambassadeur de
l'UNESCO vous êtes conseiller économique
et qu'est-ce que vous venez chercher ici
nous on cherche des diplômes pour
pouvoir avoir une position dans la vie
comme vous et vous c'est le sens inverse
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché monsieur
et je lui ai sorti une petite anecdote
qu'on m'a appris aussi pendant mes
modules à HEC
c'est l'anecdote de la tasse de thé
l'usage indien
qui est un professeur d'université va
voir
et qui rentre voir le sage et le sage
lui demande de s'asseoir mais le
professeur était tellement rempli de
connaissances qu'il est rentré avec un
air suffisant
le sage dit asseyez-vous monsieur
il s'assoit et ça je lui demande je vous
sers un thé c'est la tradition chez moi
il y a pas de problème volontiers
le sage mais la tasse de thé il prend la
bouilloire avec du thé dans la
bouilloire et il remplit la tasse de thé
la tasse de thé est remplie mais le sage
continue à mettre de l'eau dans la tasse
de thé et l'eau a commencé à déborder
et c'est le professeur lui-même qui dit
mais monsieur arrêtez vous ne voyez pas
que la tasse est pleine l'eau est en
train de déborder
il dit c'est comme ça que je vous ai vu
l'entrée chez moi
c'est le sage qui lui dit ça
c'est comme ça que je vous ai vu
l'entrée chez moi
vous êtes rentré chez moi rempli de
connaissances
et si vous êtes remplis de connaissance
je sais pas ce que je peux ajouter à
cette à toutes vos connaissances
je vais vous dire justement que dans la
vie souvent il faut vider un peu sa
tasse de thé pour pouvoir avoir un
nouveau contenu
et c'est ce que j'ai dit à l'étudiant
j'ai dit moi je suis venu à HEC en
vidant un peu ma tasse de thé dans ma
tasse de thé il y avait la gloire il y
avait la célébrité il y avait
toute la vie mon diabète tout ce qui
pouvait accompagner les honneurs les
distinctions et tout je les ai enlevés
je suis venu à acheter parce que j'ai
estimé qu'il manquait quelque chose à
mon pc à mon puzzle je suis venu à
prendre
et tout de suite
il a compris le sens
de l'anecdote que je voulais lui donner
je voulais lui dire que dans la vie
quelque chose ce qu'on est on se dise
toujours on a besoin de savoir plus on a
besoin de connaître plus on a besoin de
se refaire on a besoin de s'actualiser
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça dans le
portable toutes les applications ont
besoin de mise à jour permanente
nous aussi on en a besoin
et tout le monde en a parlé et quand
j'ai dit j'allais à HEC il me reste 8
minutes quand je dis j'allais acheter
mes amis de groupe mes collaborateurs ma
famille personne ne comprenait pourquoi
je voulais aller mais personne ne m'a
dissuadé
donc votre environnement peut contribuer
à vous pousser dans la réalisation de
vos rêves mais moi mon rêve il n'a pas
commencé aujourd'hui mon rêve a commencé
depuis
l'arrivée de magic System en France
parce que quand j'arrive en France déjà
j'étais déjà dans ma révolution je vous
ai dit que pour rêver
il faut se créer une évolution
j'étais déjà dans ma révolution j'arrive
je demande mais qu'est-ce qui ne marche
pas chez les autres groupes et puis
quand ils arrivent c'est un à deux ans
après on entend plus parler d'eux
on ne parle que d'Alpha Blondy on ne
parle que de Youssou N'Dour mais parce
qu'ils sont dans les majors comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour aller dans les
majors je me renseigne on me dit non
mais il faut avoir un contact avec les
patrons et je connais aucun patron je
m'appelle la Salfo je viens dans le
mambo comment est-ce que je vais parler
avec des patrons comme le Laurent
chapeau et tout ça
j'ai la chance une opportunité
l'avènement
du numérique
donc je me mets à apprendre comment on
envoie un mail parce que quand tu viens
dans lumumbo tu as pas un ordinateur
donc je me mets à prendre comment est-ce
qu'on envoie un mail et j'arrive à
envoyer de mails et tout de suite comme
j'ai la chance d'avoir la belle et
rédaction aussi donc tout de suite on
répond à mes mails et puis voilà avec
ses collections
je vais pas vous donner les détails mais
j'arrive à faire de Magic System l'une
des références en matière de matière
musique africaine parce que je suis
exigeant sur moi-même et sur la manière
de fonctionner de mon groupe et ce que
j'avais en face respectait cette vision
que j'avais de porter mon groupe avec
moi
mais ce que je vais vous dire en
réalisant vos rêves il y a des choses
qui vont vous bloquer il y a des
difficultés qui vont vous toucher
et il y a des difficultés qui peuvent
vous amener à dire ce n'est plus la
peine de continuer parce que vous êtes à
faire ça et vous croyez que vous ne
pouvez plus avancer maintenant c'est
faux
c'est faux on ne peut pas réaliser son
rêve sans des erreurs
c'est faux il y a des difficultés je
vais vous donner un exemple de
difficulté je vais pas vous emmener en
arrière je vais vous emmener dans un
exemple où tout le monde dans la salle a
été témoin
c'était pendant la crise de la covid en
Côte d'Ivoire
il y a eu le scandale de ma famille qui
n'a pas voulu être à l'INJS et j'ai été
sous le vindicte de toute la Côte
d'Ivoire je crois que dans cette salle
même si on enlève deux ou trois
personnes tout le reste était dedans
mais j'ai reconnu mon tort c'est une
erreur je suis un être humain je suis
amené à combien des erreurs j'ai reconnu
mon toit mon instinct paternel a pris le
dessus sur l'intérêt général parce que
j'ai voulu sortir mes enfants d'un point
où je voulais pas que qu'elle se fasse
contaminer
j'ai reconnu mon tort j'ai demandé
pardon mais j'ai ouvert ma fessée là
parce que pendant plus de 15 jours
toutes les a serviettes ont été dites
sur moi tout ce qui était mauvais on m'a
traité de tout comme si on venait de
découvrir un monstre
et ça je pouvais m'asseoir et dire c'est
fini pour moi
je pouvais m'enterrer là je pouvais dire
non mais non si vous avez remarqué
j'avais un objectif je suis allé là
et pendant cette covid je dis il y a un
élan de solidarité je suis dans cet élan
de solidarité
j'ai essayé de mobiliser des fonds des
partenaires j'ai eu près de 1 million
200000 euros
qu'on a investi dans le vivre et tout ça
pour pouvoir aider parce que j'étais
focus sur mon rêve et mon rêve c'était
un rêve qui est extensible ce n'est pas
un rêve fixe c'est un rêve dans lequel
il y a de la transversalité et je suis
resté dans ce rêve
j'ai pu aider
parce que pour moi c'est pas ça donc des
choses pires peuvent arriver où vous
allez croire que vous ne servez à rien
tout ce que vous faites c'est nul les
gens sont un grand envers vous les gens
non c'est pas ce genre de choses tu dois
vous détourner de votre rêve soyez focus
soyez focus et aujourd'hui
dans cette même continuité puisque moi
mon rêve il n'est pas encore fini
je vais retourner encore à l'école
c'est pas une exclusivité je sais que
vous saviez que j'allais le continuer
donc
je vais retourner à l'école parce que
j'ai estimé que c'est pas fini
je veux être au service de ma communauté
ma petite communauté à moi c'est manadia
au bout de que je remercie qui sont là
ce soir
mais je vais servir ma grande communauté
j'ai compris en allant à l'école que le
monde de la musique les auteurs
compositeurs les artistes en Côte
d'Ivoire
ne s'en sortent pas les vivaient pas de
leurs yeux
et j'en faisais partie quand j'étais pas
encore en France
et à HEC quand on m'a demandé de choisir
un thème à soutenir pour mon mémoire
j'ai choisi la récupération automatisée
des droits des lieux publics la
répartition juste des droits d'auteur et
j'ai travaillé j'ai cherché
j'ai eu presque toutes les lois de 8
pays de l'uemo a concernant les droits
d'auteur je suis allé relire toutes les
lois en France pour sortir la
problématique qui n'allait pas et
je crois que je suis sur la bonne route
de résoudre ce problème parce que le
test a été fait la solution a été
proposée au bureau dans le test a été
fait dans toute la Côte d'Ivoire et ça a
été concluant et aujourd'hui nous sommes
en train de signer un accord qui va
révolutionner
[Applaudissements]
tu vas révolutionner
la vie des auteurs compositeurs en Côte
d'Ivoire et c'est pourquoi je dis moi
mon rêve est extensible je ne veux pas
m'arrêter aujourd'hui ça va aider ça va
permettre des artistes de vivre et tout
mais ça fait partie de mauvaises je me
suis dit si je réussis faut que j'aide
les autres parce que moi j'ai cherché
cette aide là quand j'étais en novembre
sans que personne ne m'étendre la main
et je sais ce que c'est attendre que
quelqu'un vienne m'aider et quand tu le
sais quand tu as la fenêtre que tu vois
quelqu'un passer dans les mêmes
conditions que toi tu as envie de
l'appeler pour lui dire à mon époque
c'était comme toi j'avais besoin de
soutien je décide de te donner mon
soutien et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire tout au long de ma vie la
Fondation magique si ça m'a été mise en
place pour ça
pour aider les enfants dans un premier
temps dans lumumbo
à ne pas vivre ce que nous nous avons
vécu
et donc dans mon rêve mon rêve a changé
de vie mon rêve va changer ma vie
et je voulais même pas quitter à noumbo
sans avoir laissé une trace indélébile
j'essaye avec manager
des écoles on va construire des hôpitaux
et puis après on va voir et on arrivait
à le faire ça change la vie des
populations
chers amis moi j'ai envie de vous dire
quelque chose
le rêve il le permet
donnez-vous les moyens de réaliser vos
rêves en 1998 nous regardions la finale
de la Coupe du monde à la télévision ou
Zinédine Zidane soulève la Coupe du
monde et on était là on était dans un
rêve on ne savait pas qu'en 2018
c'est-à-dire près de 20 ans après nous
serons acteurs dans ce même stade avec
la Coupe du monde à la main en train de
courir avec l'équipe de France rêver
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]